ينضم الينا من غلاف غزه مراسلنا الياس
كرام الياس اهلا بك كيف يسير الجيش
الاسرائيلي عملياته العسكريه في غزه وهو
يعد مزيدا من القتلى في صفوف جنوده
يوميا نعم هو يقول بان هذه العمليات
متواصله وان كان بزخم اقل على الاقل في
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه الذي سحب منها
عددا كبيرا من قواتها بما في ذلك الفرقه
رقم
36 لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زال يشير الى
ان قواته ما زالت تعمل ضمن عمليات محدوده
الاهداف ومحدوده الاماكن بمعنى عمليات يتم
تنفيذها وفق مخططات او وفق معلومات بعينها
راينا بالامس كيف ان الجيش الاسرائيلي عاد
ليتوغل من جديد في المناطق الشرقيه لمخيم
جباليا واشتبك مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي ابدت باسا شديدا في مقاومه ومواجهه
القوات الاسرائيليه واكدت على انها ما
زالت قادره على مواجهه القوات الاسرائيليه
في تلك المناطق التي ينسحب منها الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعلن هذا الصباح عن مقتل ضابط
وجندي وكان لافتا ان مقتل هؤلاء الاثنين
ايه كان في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
بمعنى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زال يمنى
بخسائر على الصعيد البشري وعلى الصعيد
الاليات العسكريه راينا بالامس ان
الاشتباكات التي كانت في مخيم جباليا و
وهي يبدو انها مستمره لان هنالك بعض سحب
الدخان التي تتصاعد في تلك ال المناطق
وكانها اعادت العمليات العسكريه الى
الايام الاولى للعمليه البريه القصف الجوي
والمدفعي لم يتوقف على المناطق الشماليه
للقطاع كما لم يتوقف على الضواحي الشماليه
لمدينه غزه الشجاعيه هذا الحي الواقع في
شرق مدينه غزه كان ايضا عرضه للقصف
المدفعي الشديد وكذلك المناطق الجنوبيه
عدا عن ذلك الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن هذا
الصباح انه تمكن من الوصول الى منصه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت منها الصواريخ يوم
امس باتجاه مدينه نيتي فو في النقب الغربي
وقال ان اللواء 646 الذي يعمل في المناطق
الوسطى لقطاع غزه قد وصل الى هذا الموقع
وعثر على ثلاث منصات للصواريخ كل واحده
تشمل على عشر فوهات للاطلاق وكانت محشوه
بالصواريخ المعده للاطلاق الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال بانه دمر هذه المنصات ومنع
الخطر منها خطر اطلاق مزيد من الصواريخ
باتجاه النقب الغربي بطبيعه الحال بلديه
نيتي فوت كانت قالت امس بان الدفعه
الصاروخيه التي وجهت ضد المدينه اشتملت
على 50 صاروخا بعض هذه الصواريخ تم
اعتراضها من جانب منظومه القبه الحديديه
لكن عدد اخر تمكن من اختراق الدفاعات
الجويه وسقط في داخل المدينه محدثا اضرارا
في المباني العامه والتجاريه وبعض
الصواريخ الاخرى ايضا سقطت فيما يعرف
بالمجلس الاقليمي سدوت نجف في بعض البلدات
الاسرائيليه المجاوره والقريبه من منطقه
غلاف غزه واحدثت بعض الصواريخ دمارا كبيرا
ايضا في المنشات العامه و المباني الخاصه
11000 صاروخ اطلقت خلال هذه الحرب من كافه
الجبهات 9000 منها تقريبا من داخل قطاع
غزه لكن وقع الصواريخ ال 50 التي اطلقت
بالامس باتجاه نيتي فوت ربما يكون الاكبر
على اعتبار انه اشار الى ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت تملك القدره الصاروخيه
والعسكريه وانه في الاماكن التي ينسحب
منها الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زالت المقا
المقاومه الفلسطينيه قادره على العوده
واثبات قدراتها وسيطرتها ليس فقط العسكريه
انما المدنيه وهذا جر كثيرا من الانتقادات
من جانب وزراء في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من بينهم بطبيعه الحال ايتمار
بنفير وزير الامن القومي الذي احتج على
انسحاب الجيش الاسرائيلي من المناطق
الوسطى وسحب الفرقه 36 وقال ان سحب الجيش
الاسرائيلي سيترتب عليه خسائر بشريه
بالنسبه لاسرائيل
ودعوات اخرى من جانب وزراء اخرين في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الذين قالوا على ان
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يجب ان يبقى في داخل
قطاع غزه وان يواصل عملياته العسكريه لان
المهمه لم تنجز بعد بحسب ما قالوه وانه في
الاماكن التي ينسحب منها الجيش الاسرائيلي
واضح بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه تعود لتملا
هذا الفراغ وتنشط عسكريا ضد القوات
الاسرائيليه هذه الاطلاقات الصاروخيه التي
كانت موجهه ضد نيتي فوت احرجت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ايضا لانها جاءت بعد اقل من 4
ساعه من اعلان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف
جلنت عن انتهاء العمليات الاسرائيليه
الكبرى في المناطق الشماليه وبطبيعه الحال
احرجت موقف جلنت واحرجت موقف من كان يعتقد
بان اسرائيل انجزت المهمه في المناطق
الشماليه وانها باتت تنطق
ربما الى المرحله الثالثه من هذه العمليات
وهي سحب القوات على الاقل او اعاده
انتشارها وتموضع في مناطق قريبه من السياج
الامني او في منطقه غلاف غزه والبدء في
عمليات نوعيه خاصه
ومحدده المعالم دا عن ذلك الجيش
الاسرائيلي حتى هذه الساعه لم يعلن رسميا
عن السماح بعوده الفلسطينيين الذين هجروا
من ديارهم في المناطق الشماليه الى
منازلهم و وهنالك بطبيعه الحال ايضا اصوات
تتعالى في اسرائيل في هذا الشان تقول على
ان اسرائيل يجب ان تبقي هذه المساله كورقه
ضغط وكور مساومه اي في اي في اطار اي
مفاوضات لاطلاق صفقه جديده لتبادل الاسرار
نحن ما زلنا هنا في المناطق الوسطى لقطاع
غزه ونسمع بين الحين والاخر ايضا تحليقا
كثيفا للمروحيات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
التي ما زالت تنشط في اجواء
المنطقه الصف المدفعي المتقطع هذا اليوم
باتجاه نعم تحليق الطائرات
وتيره تختلف
و نعم بالنظر الى ما يقوله الجيش
الاسرائيلي الياس بان هذه المرحله تكون
فيها العمليات محدوده الاهداف والاماكن
ويتم فيها سحب بعض القوات لكن مما
تشاهدونه انتم من غلاف غزه كيف يتجسد هذا
الكلام عن هذه المرحله عسكريا و وميدانيا
من خلال وتيره القصف والعمليات العسكريه
وضرتها لو قارنا ما يجري في الايام
الاخيره مقارنه مع الايام الاولى للعمليه
واضح تماما بان حجم الغارات الجويه والقصف
المدفعي والقصف البحري قد قل بشكل كبير
وان كان في بعض الاحيان هذا القصف وهذه
الغارات تشتد حينا وتخف حينا اخر بطبيعه
الحال هذا يترتب على ما يجري في مدان
المعركه بمعنى عندما تعلق القوات
الاسرائيليه في مازق او في ورطه في اطار
العمليات البريه المستمره في بعض المحاور
القتال هي تستدعي اسنادا ناريا مكثفا سواء
كان ذلك من جانب سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي او
من جانب المدفعيه الاسرائيليه التي تنشط
احيانا في دك وضرب بعض المواقع التابعه
للمقاومه ال الفلسطينيه لكن بالمجمل العام
الصوره تغيرت تماما وتبدلت بمعنى اننا لم
نعد نرى هذه الكميه الكبيره للغارات
الجويه والقصف المدفعي الكبير وهذا ما
يفسر حقيقه ان الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليا
انتقل الى مرحله جديده في اداره العمليات
العسكريه هو لا يقول بان الحرب انتهت او
ان العمليات العسكريه انتهت لكن ربما يكون
النهج قد اختلف في التعاطي مع العمليات
العسكريه وهو ما يفسر عمليا انسحاب الجيش
الاسرائيلي او اعاده تموضعه وانتشاره في
مواقع بعينها في داخل قطاع غزه او في
منطقه غلاف غزه
وهذه هذا الاماكن اصبحت الان منطلقا للجيش
الاسرائيلي لتنفيذ عمليات محدوده او
توغلات محدوده او اعاده القيام بعمليات
عسكريه في داخل قطاع غزه كما جرى اليوم في
المخيمات الوسطى عندما دخلت قوه عسكريه
مجددا الى هناك من اجل تدمير منصات
الصواريخ التي انطلقت منها الصواريخ
باتجاه مدينه نتيفوت صباح امس الياس كرام
من غلاف غزه شكرا جزيلا
لك